I'd like you to imagine what it would
feel like if for two whole minutes your
left arm was continuously flapping your
eyes were constantly rolling your jaw
was clenching so hard that I felt like
your teeth were about to break in every
ten seconds you were forced to let out a
loud high-pitched screech this is how I
lived at the young age of six every
waking moment seven days a week and
these are only some of my symptoms only
symptoms surfaced my life literally
changed overnight I could no longer go
to school see my friends or even eat out
because my tics would attract the
attention of everyone in the room in
search for a cure we flew to New York to
meet with the best pediatric
neuropsychologist my parents could find
but the doctor did not give us the easy
remedy we had hoped for
instead she diagnosed me with an
incurable neurological disorder
Tourette's syndrome often times
medication can be an essential and
valuable part of many treatment
processes but in my case the drugs only
made things worse
one drug put me in a wheelchair because
my legs had gotten so numb that I
couldn't move them another one caused me
to hallucinate I would see green people
running after me threatening to boil me
in a pot and drink me a soup and it was
really scary we try drug after drug to
find something that would bring me some
sort of relief but every single attempt
just ended up making things worse it is
estimated that in 2013 in the United
States alone the prescription drug
expenditure to treat neurological
conditions and mental illness was about
89 billion dollars annually
but imagine if there were a way to treat
these conditions without without a price
or without side effects imagine if your
doctor prescribed you a daily dose of
music I'm here today to share with you
my personal experience with music and
the effect that it had on my
neurological disorder Tourette syndrome
is essentially a series of involuntary
movements and sounds known as tics the
best way for me to really describe what
it's like to have Tourette's syndrome is
something I'm sure you're all very
familiar with the hiccups you can try to
stop yourself from the act you can hold
your breath and count to ten or drink
water upside down but there is just
nothing you can do about it and so the
sensation passes and the hiccups have
taken their course I often lay on my
bedroom floor after an attack of ticks
feeling exhausted and in despair my
equally desperate mother would attempt
to soothe me and herself by putting on
some music
she would play peaceful music to soothe
our aching hearts and we lie together on
the floor and allow the beat of the
drums to uplift us and as the rhythms
and the tunes unfolded our spirits would
rise our moods would be lighter and we
would be rejuvenated very soon and
rather unknowingly I became an addict of
this newfound drug when I found myself
slipping into my bouts of sadness and
self-pity I would rush to the 88 keys of
my piano knowing in my heart that the
tones and rhythms from each one of those
keys would soon set me free at the time
I didn't realize how much music was
helping me it was just something I did
by default when I wrote my songs it
wasn't to impress anybody it was just a
release but the more I played the less
my symptoms surfaced and the intensity
of my attacks reduced so I became
curious as to how these songs were
soothing my symptoms and I wondered if
there were any of there were any other
cases of medicinal music so I began to
search I found that there was a highly
successful us congresswoman Gabby
Giffords who was shot in the head
she lost her ability to speak because
the ability to speak and the ability to
sing lay in two separate parts of the
brain her doctors brought in music
therapists to work with her the
therapist encouraged her to sing her
thoughts since she was incapable of
speaking them and through this technique
the congresswoman was finally able to
regain her speech music helped heal
gabby giffords
scientists have found that music causes
our brains to release a natural pain
killer known as oxytocin and a feel-good
chemical dopamine dopamine is essential
for a healthy nervous system and
strongly impacts emotional health music
also affects our heart rate breathing
and pulse rate as it stimulates blood
flow in addition it lowers our cortisol
levels thus reducing anxiety which is a
coolant for neurological symptoms in our
lifetimes we are all going to know
someone with a neurological disorder if
it's not a family member it could be a
friend or a co-worker please help me
spread this message music has the
ability to uplift our lives and heal us
from within
I still have Tourette syndrome I deal
with it every day every hour I'm going
to deal with it for the rest of my life
and that means that I have to frequently
excuse myself from my classroom because
my verbal tics can be extremely
distracting that means that sometimes
when I wink my eyes involuntarily the
guy sitting opposite from me thinks I'm
flirting with him when I'm really not
and I have to tell him sorry like I
wasn't trying to flirt but the most
amazing thing is that when I sing play
music and even just listen to music I
don't take I've been onstage numerous
times in highly stressful situations
with thousands of people watching me and
while I do take perform my performance
when the music starts the tics take a
back seat so I may have written my own
lyrics and composed my own music but in
reality I realized it was the music that
composed me thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I took my mask of too soon
CoA there is any one bite I think I
pushed you see you should have tried it
out check it out if maybe Eastern Adams
a bit of myself I put it back on just to
fake it celebrate Oh
oh no me me me take it seriously
not me you will never be you
I'm not me you I thought I could trust
you but you running away from
Mama's gonna meet you bu bu
[Music]
I think I took my mask off too soon
maybe this time it more than ever maybe
I took
[Music]
and take it seriously
you know me you
I thought I could trust you but you're
running away from me Emami you know
[Music]
[Applause]